[Applause]
[Music]
hey you're back and that's a good thing
what I need you to do is like follow and
subscribe head i LP and then hit the
little bell icon of this so you can be
notified when new compact talk comes up
or when new flash points come out or
when new ILP information runs that way
you can be notified but in order to get
all the great stuff that we have for you
guys you must hit the like button and
you must subscribe see some combat talk
with the king oh boy if you miss this
end-of-the-year fight you're crazy I
want you to go back catch that on replay
and replay it again see it a couple of
times
Deontay Wilder vs. Tyson Fury the WBC
heavyweight champion of the world versus
the Linea heavier link champion of the
world they put on a spectacle and this
is how it exactly how it goes when you
have a spectacle of the heavyweight
championship you have the heavyweight
champions box and getting it on mixing
it up this is when the heavyweight
division is at its finest when you can
look around and say yeah this is what it
do if you pay for pay-per-view last
night you got your money's worth
these boys did not fail to display their
talents a lot of people's out of here
screaming yeah a wild allow he didn't
win it come on man
Tyson Fury did it man you got to do more
than stick your tongue out and move your
hands behind your back to fool anybody
bro that's not landed a punch
that's not ring generalship that's not
controlling the circle that's not
aggression
that's just buffoonery gets no points
from me
alright somebody give you guys a lot of
breakdowns there's a lot of you guys
watch fights don't lift fights never
fought a fight couch potatoes that's why
I'm here to give you that real give you
that skinny to give you exactly what
went on
now when you have two heavyweights of
this magnitude that means you have two
powerful promoters usually there's one
judge on one side one promoter there's
one judge on the other side for the
other promoter then you've got this
neutral judge okay now
smoochie judge the judge is gonna call
the street down the line
now you have one judge that had it 114
112 I sign fury then you have one judge
that had it 115-113 J on tape wild out
then you have one judge that had it and
even draw 113 to 113 now that's the guy
to put salt in your booth
that's the guy to rained on your parade
and that's the guy that called it right
let me give you why round one
Deontay Wilder effective aggression
round two Deontay Wilder effective
aggression round three Tyson Fury jabs
round full Tyson Fury jab right hand
sneaky left hook that was what running
won him the round if he counted as two
rounds even round three Tyson Fury uh-oh
I mean Tyson Fury is up three rounds to
two now that's five gone uh-oh
round six Tyson Fury uh-oh
take some Fury's up two rounds round
seven Deontay Wilder Oh Oh Tyson Fury is
up one round round eight Tyson Fury
takes the foodies up two rounds round
nine Deontay Wilder scores are knocked
down of Tyson Fury two-point round not
even what the king when I knocked down
is scored is a 10-8 round for the guy
who knocked down the opponent learn the
rules round 10 Tyson Fury taste the food
isn't one round round 11 Tyson Fury
thanks of free man get out of this
did the championship go back across the
pond round 12
Deontay Wilder scores another knockdown
zips them up and puts them in a body bag
technically speaking well we're going to
get into the long count from the referee
we're going to get into the miraculous
wake up over Tyson Fury so now you have
a two-point round when Tyson Fury was up
two points even fight 113 to 113 that's
the judge that put blood in your snow
now you upset because they judge the
sword for effective aggression they're
awarded aggression heating care if Tyson
Fury was landing a jab he sawed the ante
while they're trying to take his head
off he sawed Deontay Wilder actively
trying to kill his man he saw Deontay
Wilder the heavyweight champion of the
world going out to try to win so he
scored all the if he if he rounds
for Deontay Wilder that's how you got
the 115-113
because that guy likes a fight a dust-up
the other one the other judge who loves
the sweet science who love the slipping
and dipping in the shoulder movement the
left hooks the right hands the flick of
the jab
followed by a straight right hand quote
by the left look they're switching from
Orthodox to southpaw did dip in low when
the right hand comes just to come up
with the left hook uppercut shot that
guy's caught him for Tyson Fury 114 112
it's not a large margin fellas so he was
still giving around to Deontay Wilder
you can't be upset with what you saw
because what you saw was what we
supposed to get we're supposed to get a
spectacle when heavyweights get in the
ring
we're supposed to get that boombastic
that bombastic fighting if you watched
it on pay-per-view you got your money's
worth you know it I know it now let's go
into the 246 pound
boxing on his toes from round one around
12 let's go into the 246 pounds to be
400 pounds that abused his body with all
types of drugs with coke and alcohol
getting knocked down knocked out with a
right hand left hook hit the canvas and
got up like the Undertaker from the Long
Count for the referee the referee
thought he was dead
then he popped up boom Deontay Wilder
thought he was dead
and celebrating so you might say King
were you casting aspersions man your
feelings is hurt
Deontay Wilder you know I'm saying he
lost that fight cake you like to eat
that one
let me tell you something in that drawer
ain't steal anytime the more fit fighter
is gasping for breath item the more out
of shape fighter at the end of a fight
some no smell right he had a Freddie
Roach to his camp did Tyson Fury not
have the same energy as Manny Pacquiao
and early is just saying though I'm not
saying but I'm saying we all need to
understand one thing
those men embraced and hugged each other
at the end because when you can dance
the dance of death with a man for 45
minutes there's a lot of truths that are
told in that ring there's no lies
between those ropes you are who you are
I told you Deontay Wilder had unwavering
belief in himself I told you that even
through the adversity where he was
getting beat boxing it's not the
smoothest boxer it's probably one of the
most effective boxes he's not how you
train a young fighter to fight but how
the hell can you argue with his resume
41 and old with 39 knockouts no brother
mm-hmm well 41 draw and 39 knockouts
I scored it as a winner I'm that 114 112
do but I just gave you the skinny high
that drawer came out and my day you had
to beat the champ to beat a champ all
that sweet cute cute stuff sticking your
tongue out Japeth all right hand brother
but this goes into Showtime putting out
those hits this whole year shows time
kept delivering our Heyman I thank you
so much as a fight fan for putting these
things together and 2019 was sure enough
be another bombastic year if you saw
that stadium it was packed to the brim
they probably would selling standing
room tickets
you had the local MCS come out the game
j-rok beautiful production
out to everyone involved I pray that
Tyson Fury was clean I don't want this
to sully what turned out to be a great
performance from a guy that had faced so
much adversity but then they asked me to
have confidence and somebody that has a
questionable past can't do that bro this
is combat talk with the king get high or
fall behind I in Lords podcast
[Applause]
[Music]